POLITICAL COTA
FORMER OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
JASON, LET'S START WITD
Y
ON CAPDAY WERE
MINUTES
ATERED.F, I THOUGHT YOU DID A
>> MATADOR. D THE BEOB ULEXPECTB
NIRERUN.TH TRUMP'SENANM SAPPOIN
LECT THAT ANT IT
AROR
I'M PRIZED WE HA THAT WERE WILA.
ER SOME THAT DONT IN THE NOISE O
.
I COMMEND THAT.
LET THE DOWN A
>> AU G THTEANAT THINK
MADO
ANER DONALITS A VERYO, JUSIN NO.
THOUGHT IT WAA
POSITION PWAS A REPEK THOUGHT AI
BEFORE
S MAKE GREATN FROM THEHA
Y  R PERIO'ST .RI, JUTWYEO YEARC
YOU SEE THE S ATE
INAND
ONE OF HRG
WON'T PTS
PIT IN THE REPUBLIIMARY
IS
BUT HE DIDN'T SPEND LOT OF
TIME TNG BIDENR HI
I WAS VERY EC EVERYONE
Y NDERYOUR YOU DT LE
YEARS.IEFING ROOM OV T
I THINK HE W -IN THERE AND I HA
HEARING THE'S INVOT TOWARD BIDE.
HE GOING
IG ASN
ENCUMBENT,D TRO
THERE ISN'T REALLY A REPLI
HICHALLENGERS.TO GIVE OU
HEAN'T STOP DEFENDING MS
OR TALKING ABOUT HIMSELF, SO
IMING ABDEN.
THAT WILL BE A PROBLEM F
AND IS, HE
WANTS TO TALELF AND
S POINT.
I THINK HIS STL  ABOUT THE CONT.
I THINTH TIS
GOING TOO APPEAR
OR STRONG AN TW WEAKNESS
N.AGAIN, THIS PRIMARY'AT HE'NOM
LOOKING. I ALSS STRUCK BY, HE
TO MIX IT UPO
ON STAGE.
DE.K THERA  CHANCOT GOING TO
TWO.
F
ONE OUT. 'M GOING TO SIT THIS
>> DAVID, WHAT'S YOUR SENSE
E RESPONDING
YOU SAW TODAY?
FACT  WATLIU
WANT FOUR MORE YEARSEY'RE FUNDR
AMICS DON'THIS HALLS-OWHAT
THOSE YEARS WEREHAIC.
THINK THAT'S STRATEGICALLY WAS .
IN TERMS OF HOS
UST
REALITY CHECK, THETHY THEYAUS EE
IS THET FORCE IN S BASE, WHI
BLOLTODAY, I
FAIRLY SUBSTANTIALR
PEOP SD ER VIEWS WHO WISH THAT '
LIKE ARULY.NDED LIKE A TRUSE CNE
REPRESTAF IC
HAMPSHIRE. THE POLLS
THE GOVERNOR OF THE STE IS
SA.
A DOMINANTION. WHAT YOU SAW T
TO COMMENTITI HATE T MANU RAJU,L
YOU KNOW'SPLAGUE OR SOMETHING,
NETO A
ABY DON'T WANTTO OFFEND OFHENGS
ARGOG TO HAVE TO DECE E THEY GOE
OF THOSE DOORS.
E  KNOW, BEHAG
AND HAVE NOTHING TO SAY ABOUT
IS THAALLYNGE R  -
OFOU'RE , BUI
EAN? CARCAMPGN  T WHAT TRUMP
WAS DOING.
RY SINE
TOFTIME, THE HILL, ATINTRUMP?
AT THE TIME THST
WAS, THERE'S NO WAY THIS GG WEHT
SO I T SOF THESE MEMBERS -- U SA
SAMPLEOMS THEY.DON'T KNOW HOW M
OVERALLE'SO
TARI WE HAITH RIGHT NOHE LAST T
>> IS,EYE TALKARGEEC
TWTHINGS. .
CAME OUT OTHIS TOWN HALL, ANI T
PEOPLE TO HEAR WHERE H ON
TI OPPOSEDS WHARE ON THE
OCS X
DOES OR WHATAVNUMBERWOS STRUCK H
PEOPLE WHO DIDN'WAO SA
AN
MONTHS, WHO HAD
BEENOUUMP
BUSTECO THINK THAT'SNGDIN A S WP
PEOPLE HAV VERY CRITICAL
HOW CAN YO THIS?ENDONALD TRUMP
THAT THE
TRUE.NOW PE A AWAREN IT'T
ATK, IT'S REAL, AN BE VERY
HO
>>16, PEOPLE D
RED,T THINK  THE GUY BECAME PRE
LYIND ALL OFSTSPEAKING,
PERFORPRETTY SUBSTANTIAL, HENOWS
HIS BASE AND HE S
TICK IT WILL FE OF
BASE, AND HE'S INCREDIBLY THROU,
AS KIND ROT HE IS  LOW WAGON DO
DEEP STATE WHO ARE
STOP HIM FROM WINNING.
>> AND ON THAT, ONG WSOME OF E
REPUBLANTING IN THE
NEW HAMPSHIRIMY.E UNDECLARED VOF
JEANRO CERTAINLY PEOPLFELTOMLET
SAYING, MAYBE WE'LL SIGHIM
TI THE DOCUMENTS, DO YOU THINK
EXPO D CIN DOUBLE TAKE
IN THE NEWOU  QIOD HE
ANSWERED THE WAY HE
SPECIFIC MOMENT
OF THE TOWN LL YOU WERBO
STANDING
IT'S NOT A TOPIC HNGUAGE
VERY WORRIED, AS YOU KNOW,
AND HED HIMSELF
TROUBL
HE SAID, TOOK THEM.WED TO.
HE'S DONE SLIGHT VARIATI